did not much meat in danger to the dodge
handle staff and his son speak German
but Elliott also speaks Danish like his
mom eager to join the conversation when
his wife and child are chatting in her
native language Hans is learning Danish
via the online language learning tool
baba it costs 10 euros a month the
program gives him vocabulary tests and
corrects his pronunciation and bubble
bubble allows me to learn on my time not
somebody else's it's also cheap compared
to other language learning programs and
I just like the idea of a little company
from Berlin conquering the world through
languages canastota nameless poline
Mitch patent ivetta avada bubble users
can choose from 13 languages english
spanish french but also Indonesian
Turkish and Danish but whatever language
you're learning there will always be
problems rendering specific sayings a
bit of a headache for the software
developers there's an Italian saying
aviron yoga for rtd prosciutto which
literally means having your eyes wrapped
in ham that is being blind to the
obvious in order to give students an
image of that I had myself photographed
with ham on my eyes that picture is
still featured on baubles Italian
section for food related phrases Baba's
workforce comprises 180 people from 19
different countries and counting they're
also for the more Marcus Vita is part of
the team that founded Baba in 2007 the
program now has more than 16 million
users and recently expanded into the US
market no maken because each husband
this is a rapidly developing market and
knowledge is crucial place a the firm we
bought up in California generated
knowledge in the five
that have been operating in the mobile
language learning segment what we want
is market knowledge and a presence on
the local market sundus moccasin
standard indium indiamart the Berlin
company already claims to be the market
leader in Germany the team sees their
greatest competition not in the
established publishing sector which
focuses on books and CDs but in startups
with innovative ideas few doesn't animal
entities there are a lot of players and
interested investors so with all that
money available something's bound to
happen and right now we have to pave the
way side listen view what's not me weak
bond even Elliott is learning to Kent
door Charlotte chicken in Danish can you
speak German yes says Elliott Kent don't
say logician the Rafah family are
planning a temporary moved to Copenhagen
Hans will be able to continue running
his own internet company from their
brilliance from Baba Nevada see me I
wouldn't expect bother to take me to
business level proficiency the idea of
mastering a language perfectly via a
language course is the wrong approach
the essential thing is making herself
understood you learn the rest once
you're in the country Elliott can order
an ice cream by himself a crucial summer
skill that Hans goof-off has also
mastered in Danish but he has quite a
few lessons ahead of him to be able to
work full-time in Copenhagen